another close race this morning the
battle for two congressional seats
currently held by democrats susie lee
and stephen horsford they represent
districts three and four in the nation's
capital
hector mejia is live this morning in the
west part of town with details on those
races
hey hector john and as you mentioned
this one is way too close to call first
term democrats suzula and steven
horsford
both trying to hold on to their seats
and we're live in this part of town
because we are live
we are standing right in between
district 3 and 4 the ones they represent
let's go ahead and take a look at vote
totals so far with a record number of
votes this year
ballots are still being counted and this
morning it's still
unclear how many more are left to come
in when it comes to this race
so far congresswoman susie lee has a
slim
lead over republican challenger dan
rodimer he's a former professional
wrestler
district 3 covers the south valley which
includes part of las vegas
henderson and boulder city in district 4
congressman stephen horsford is also in
the lead
his republican challenger is former
state assemblyman jim marchand
that district covers part of las vegas
and the central portion of the state
last night we went to events held by
both parties we caught up with
challenger jim marchant
he was confident he'd get the votes
necessary to take the seat
we're cautiously optimistic and we were
under no illusion this was going to be
an easy race
but we worked as hard as we could work
to
win this race and if a republican can
win this district we'll do it this cycle
the campaign between suzy lee and dan
rodimer was perhaps the most
contentious with a firestorm of negative
political ads
and again early numbers show that
democrats are in the lead for districts
three
and four but again we still do not know
how many more votes are left to be
counted when it comes
to these particular races reporting live
this morning hector mejia
8 news now